we are mourning the loss of a legend a
woman who's meant a lot to this show
someone who has been an inspiration to
me someone who has been an inspiration
to Millions to young women and young men
and young non-binary people it is a sad
day in America but a very sad day in
Chicago
please
there she is
[Music]
thank you
yeah
[Music]
vote vote vote
yep
here she is celebrating Chicago having
the highest murder rate in the country
with their wife and be happy and like
she'll always be able to tell people
like later on she'll be on some like
lesbian cruise and they'll be like what
did you do and she'll go I was the mayor
of Chicago and you go Laurie was the
mayor of Chicago she just cheated at
cards